hey guys Pete peppers here this is a
candy crush saga or jelly saga level 91
walkthrough with some commentary this is
a tough level because there's a ton of
blockers and there's also coils that
fall from the dispensers at the top so
you can see my strategy in the beginning
is I'm trying to look for ways to use
the dark purple candy to get some some
good what I'm what I really want to do
is I want to get you know some match
fives with those that's gonna give us a
a nice bomb but just kind of gotta play
strategically I wanna I want to keep
track of how if I can I want to if you
know I want to make a good move where I
can hit one of the coils so that I don't
get a big line of them to drop like that
one but at the same time you know that
sort of goes in cycles so we get a
chance to clear them out just as fast as
they come so here we got a bomb with the
striped it was nice that it was actually
on the jelly to just because that'll
help us I mean the problem we have isn't
going to be to spread the jam as much as
it is going to be to get rid of all the
blockers but the earlier and there we go
we set up a dark purple bomb right here
we'll take a layer off everything and
that's why I was saying you know the
jelly will spread as we're doing that so
what we really want to focus on is
clearing the blockers and we want to do
that with bombs because that's the
quickest way to open things up if you
you know if it comes up you can try to
make like a trip to the bottom like here
where you can go like sideways to but
really just scan skin I was just
scanning the board here and looking for
the best match that I can find I'm
looking for places where I can set up
bombs like I did right there so you know
you look for those pairs of candies are
the same color with a little gap in
between and see if you can't drop the
fifth one in the place
just like you would in any of the
previous candy crush games all right so
here we have we could use the the T
shape or the L shape I went for I mean
not the L shape but the the straight
line the for match for I did that
because I wanted to just go straight
down and you could see that one when I
did that that cleared up the board
pretty well and then I got some help in
the Cascade and here's another bomb so
we saw a 14 moves left and you know it
looks like things are going pretty well
I mean we've had a lot of nice bombs and
specials and things but there's still a
long way to go so this is where you
really have to start planning things out
more strategically and I don't want to I
don't want to waste this bombed at the
bottom on a on a dark purple candy I
want to keep those and I'm going to look
for these kinds of matches to the square
like the fish match for the dark purples
because the less blockers I have and the
less come you know ones I have that
aren't covered with jelly the more
certain I'll be that they're going to do
they're going to do something productive
each time I do it that'll be for fish
that are gonna help out a lot so not a
lot of good moves here so I'm just
trying to bring things down a bit get
rid of some of those get rid of some of
those coils then you can see you know
now we have nine moves and we haven't
made that much progress so just want to
take our time to find the best match
that we can get I setup the sideways
match for here I was just looking for a
second to see if I couldn't make it into
a match five but that's a pretty good
result and while we are looking for
specials you know we don't want to we
don't want to overlook the fact
sometimes we can just do direct damage
like with this orange match here and
that also gets those coils out of the
way so if we can get some something's
going down it won't get blocked or going
sideways okay so now we have just two
squares there's no immediate match
that's gonna set them off I could set
this fish and it would hit one of them
and now I have two and I'm just going to
go up in this top left corner because I
can see that I can I don't know if I can
side off the green fish at the bottom
but I could see that I can put two fish
together right there and that'll go down
to the bottom so the main you know the
main tips for this level like I said
it's really frustrating I had to play it
a few times to get through it again and
the main things to think about our you
know bombs definitely dark purple bombs
the the the dark purple coloring candy
match you know the the the mat you know
and match it has six pieces it's not
quite as good but it's pretty good too
obviously if you can get a coloring
candy plus a color bomb that'll pretty
much finish things off I I wasn't able
to set that one up just because the
coils fall each time so it's a little
bit harder to to be that deliberate but
you know obviously color bombs plus
color bombs color balance with fish
coloring candy plus fish all those are
things you want to look at and you want
to you know get said control the coils I
should go down and just really focus on
the blockers and taking out big chunks
of the blockers at the same time that's
where your you know your match floors in
a straight line and match fives in the L
shape or T shape come in handy with your
dark purple candies so I hope this helps
hang in there you'll get it soon please
like the video if you found it helpful
and be sure to subscribe to my channel
because I have a lot of these kind of
help videos and leave a comment if you
need something and I'll try to get done
with it as soon as possible
thanks